tonight's panel is about women and
science um I'll let the panelists
themselves uh get into the subject I
will introduce them briefly uh starting
from my far left is Jessica transic who
is the Atlantic Richfield Career
Development assistant professor of
energy studies um in Engineering Systems
division at MIT and is also an external
professor at the Santa Fe Institute an
odd Echo here uh um in Santa Fe she
received her BS in Material Science and
Engineering from Cornell and her PhD in
Material Science from the University of
Oxford as a road scholar um before she
arrived here she spent several years at
the Santa Fe Institute uh I guess as a
um non external professor in internal uh
um and at Columbia University as an
earth Institute Fellowship fellow where
her research focused on Energy Systems
modeling uh and her research group here
studies the dynamic costs and
environmental impact of Energy
Technologies um and how they inform
technology design and policy uh next to
Jessica is Paris seti who is an
associate professor at the center for
systems biology at Harvard um and the
department of organismic and
evolutionary biology and in the
department of immunology and infectious
diseases at the Harvard School of poal
um she's also a senior associate member
of the broad Institute located across
the street uh um she is a computational
geneticist with expertise studying
genetic diversity developing algorithms
to detect genetic signatures of natural
selection um and carrying out genetic
Association studies uh she went to MIT
as an undergrad um and also was at
Oxford as a road scholar uh and got her
medical degree from Harvard uh har
medical school as a Soros fellow if
you're interested in learning more about
pares there's an excellent um profile of
her in Smithsonian Magazine from a
couple years ago uh
that I wrote
um uh rosn Williams uh who is next to me
is the um burn gner professor of History
of Science and Technology at MIT uh she
went to Welsley and then also uh got a
ba from Harvard um and an MA from the
University of California at Berkeley uh
so despite going out to California came
back to Boston which I'm sure this
winter she's regretting um uh and also
got a PhD in history from UMass Hurst
her first three books um dream worlds
Notes From The Underground and retooling
all examined the implications for human
life both individual and Collective of
living in a predominantly
self-constructed World her most recent
book the Triumph of human Empire surveys
the overarching historical events event
of our time the rise and Triumph of
human Empire defined by the dominance of
human presence on the planet um it is my
utmost honor to welcome the three of
these speakers here um one of the
Thrills of getting to do this job is
that I can invite people that I want to
hear from and then hear from them uh so
without further Ado good there thank
you thank you for coming uh can can you
hear me no the mic is on
sufficiently
okay doesn't sound like it to me so all
right okay so thank thank you for coming
and so this is the uh the order of
business uh I will introduce well we'll
start with Jessica and then Paris
they'll both
describe their background in a less
formal way than Seth did uh it it will
be a sort of short autobiography of
interests and education like why are
they here you know how' they get here
what what's what's going on so after
that uh self- introduction then I'll
introduce myself a little bit and also
refer to some of the the history of
women in science at MIT now 20 years ago
which is startling to me to realize but
I I want to very briefly give some
context for what we're talking about uh
when we talk about women in science here
um then we will have a conversation
among ourselves this is one of these
kind of talk show conversations we're
talking to each other but there's an
audience anyway we'll see how it goes
and then around 6ish uh we'll open up
for questions from you all and when you
ask questions please come down to the
mics so it can be recorded for the the
broadcast or program the video Whatever
uh but also so I can see you it's kind
of there's glare here so uh if you want
to ask a question just stand up and and
get in line please okay so we will kick
things off Jessica okay thanks so much
and
um we all great to see all of you here
um look forward to this conversation so
I thought I'd start you know I was sort
of thinking how did I get to this point
and it's not always clear to me that
there um was like a grand plan but um I
think the story starts in high school
where I
um see here where I actually had a lot
of interests uh my fav favorite topics
were mathematics English and Fine Arts
and um you so I had some trouble
deciding what to major in um I you know
I think my my interest kind of can be
boiled down to still today uh uncovering
patterns in the human-built and natural
world uh that can be explained with
equations and with words um and then
also using design to try to make the
world a better place so that was sort of
broadly what I was interested in I
decided to study Material Science as an
undergrad and um you know what drew me
to Material Science is that uh it it's a
field that's really focusing on
understanding the basic elements that we
have here on Earth elements of the
periodic table how they can be combined
into useful materials how they are
combined into natural materials um and
then thinking of new ways to combine
these elements to to make new
technologies and and novel uh materials
with new functionalities uh so I studied
Material Science as an undergrad and
then went on to do my PhD also in
Material Science where I used Advanced
microscopy techniques to study the
structure of uh natural polymers that
have very high strength and are produced
in nature uh through energy efficient
means so I studied spider silk and
silkworm silk and a number of other
materials um and after finishing my PhD
I I really felt the need to focus on
that second interest that I mentioned
which was you know design and trying to
contribute to making making the world a
better place and and specifically I
wanted to focus on the big picture and
some you know of the global problems
that are related to engineering and
technology and I went to work for the UN
in Geneva for some time and that's where
my research shifted to a focus on Energy
Technologies and and understanding how
we can use clean energy sources that we
have here on Earth to provide useful
forms of energy for transportation and
electricity um a big part of that is
thinking how we can use materials and
elements that we have on Earth to
convert uh forms of energy you know
energy in the Sun for example to to
electricity and other um useful forms uh
so then I began really the research that
I do now which focuses on the big
picture and on the small picture at the
same time I'm interested in evaluating
Technologies for electricity for
transportation um and looking at how we
can set design targets for technologies
that can help accelerate the their
development in the lab so for example uh
one of the projects I'm really excited
about right now is one where we're
looking at how people drive around the
US the energy that they use to get from
point A to point B and we're using that
to try to set energy density targets for
batteries that are being developed in
Laboratories around the world so that's
that's one project um on another topic I
look at evaluating environmental impacts
and how much by how much we need to cut
down emissions
of greenhouse gases from various Energy
Technologies looking at how um you know
to compare methane emissions to carbon
dioxide emissions and setting targets
for emissions per unit energy of a
variety of Energy Technologies that we
use today and my group um is rather
diverse I have a group of you know men
and women coming from a variety of
fields includ including physics um
environmental engineering industrial
engineering um mathematics um as well as
economics and um you know it's it's it's
uh I'm really looking forward to talking
about this topic because I think I've
noticed firsthand how diversity in the
research group you know gender diversity
other forms of diversity really help to
uh kind of improve our our problem
solving and help us generate you know
really interesting and and and um I
think you know hopefully helpful useful
research results uh so I look forward to
this conversation thank
you sure um I'm Paretti I am uh so
Jessica and I know each other for a very
long time we were at Oxford together the
same year so this is really fun to get a
chance to do this together and I was so
thrilled when she came to MIT and was a
professor so she's one of my favorite
people in the whole world so Ro and I
was an undergraduate um and she took
care of me when I was an undergraduate
here so it's a long history um but I'll
I'll take you through that trajectory a
little bit so um I was uh born in Iran
uh in Teran Iran uh just before the
Iranian Revolution um I have with my
sister and my parents and then my kind
of larger Collective family we left
right before the kind of everything
escalated and traveled around for a long
time uh but then finally settled in in
Florida uh where I grew up so I um grew
up a very I mean I I saw I'm a
technically a child of a revolution but
I talk about that in a big way of that's
not something that is in any way
something you overcome because what you
overcome is parents who don't love you
or experiences that are sort of or or um
you know other kinds of uh experiences
sort of in your microcosm but um when
you have some political thing that your
families overcome it's actually only
motivating um and I had an amazing
mother and father who were always
incredibly encouraging to my sister and
I and who made us not even realize that
we were in some sort of a terrible
situation and uh um and as a result of
it I grew up in a household with my
grandparents and my uncles and aunts and
I shared a room with my grandmother and
my aunt and my sister and my cousin at
times and so it's a kind of a idealic
life actually because as a child you
like that I don't know kids always sleep
by themselves these days um anyway so I
and I grew up in Orlando of Florida for
the most part and um came to uh MIT as
an undergraduate um for whatever reason
I was in a lot of math advanced classes
and sort of in a woman context the my
year was one of those years where I at
times I was the only girl in my most of
my classes um then I was four of like 35
four girls of a class of 35 and then
when I went to MIT it was kind of that
year where it dipped and there was like
20% women so I've kind of always been in
an environment where there fewer women
um uh but I never really experienced
anything uh uh it was still I thought an
ideal experience um in in every way I I
love I love math I love science I loved
MIT it was an amazing place to be a
student um I saw the 270 competition or
now
2700 270 competition in when I was in
seventh grade and was like that's where
I'm going to school um and uh and then
went to Oxford with um so um with
Jessica and uh was interesting it's an
interesting place to do research I love
it uh loved it as an experience um but
it was a place where I started to see my
first sort of challenges and thinking
about what I was going to do in my life
um the from there uh went to medical
school and um and then while I was at
Oxford I ended up doing a PhD and so now
I'm a I have an MD and a PhD or it's
called a dill and do my research um in
sort of the interface of genetics um and
infectious disease and so uh a lot of
the stuff that Seth was talking about is
my core it's the work where I um develop
algorithms to mind genomic data but um
the the kind of work that I've been
doing more U sort of in a bigger way
lately is work in infectious diseases
including Ebola and lass of fever and
one of the big things our project uh our
group worked on is releasing the
sequences from the Ebola genomes U when
they became uh when the outbreak first
began and we just actually just released
another 96 and published a paper um a
commentary saying we need to make
outbreak data um Open
Access uh in any case that's a little
bit of background um and I've been on
faculty at Harvard now for about 7 years
um as far as I mean so I'm really
excited about this conversation that's
just a little bit background about
myself kinds of other things that I
didn't mention along the way is that all
along the way uh folks like Ros and
others have been these amazing mentors
for me so I didn't go into the whole
thing that we we did together which was
develop actually a Diversity Program The
Freshman leadership program was an
undergraduate um uh were ways of really
kind of inspiring young uh young
students to take leadership to take
ownership of their communities um but
I've had these amazing experiences along
the way of great mentors men and women
who have mentored me Eric Lander being
another one I've been his mentee for 21
years now um and uh obviously that's an
incredibly important thing and then
great students as well and I have a very
diverse group of individuals from
different backgrounds a broad mix of men
and women um and uh and a broad mix of
in disciplines that they come from as
well uh so that's that's a little bit
about me but we'll kind of come back to
that one too okay thank you thank you
I've got a lot of questions already I'm
sure you do too uh I will say very about
myself very briefly that uh uh my own
interests well my family background is
is very varied uh but the educated side
of the family as opposed to the
non-educated they were all in uh science
engineering especially my mother taught
math in the community college for years
um so it for me it was more like why are
you interested in history and literature
not in these other topics so though I I
I don't want to I'm overstating it
because it was a very encouraging family
whatever you're interested in but I I
felt on this fault line between my own
interests in history and literature and
the family doing engineering and science
especially engineering and
so so going into history of Technology
seemed like a way to have the best of
all worlds and I still feel that way so
I want to show you though a little of
the larger historical context for what
we're talking about because it it struck
me by the way this this is a slide that
I got from Nancy
Hopkins uh who was kind of the leader of
the pack back in the 1990s when women in
science were speaking up about their um
uh systemic discrimination uh in the
School of Science here so she gave Nancy
gave a talk in 2011 at the 150th
anniversary of MIT on this topic there
was a whole um uh special meeting on
women in science and she had a bunch of
slides and these are her slides that or
I'll show you some of them but this is
one of my favorite slides because I use
it when I when I teach history or often
in other institutions I say you want to
know what history look looks like that's
history that's change just look at it uh
so this is I'm sorry I don't have a
pointer but anyway going back to 1901 we
don't quite go back to the beginning at
MIT but just showing the flatness and
then whoops all of a sudden things start
happening and they start happening
around here in the 1960s well I
graduated in
1966 I Married An MIT Class of 65 so my
life is this upward curve all right and
uh your lives now when did you get your
phds um well yeah 2003 I think is what I
do at mine early
2000s okay so so you're you know you're
on this end of of the graph um but most
of this then you're coming into science
at least with your PhD you're also on a
sort of rising curve but it's it's a
second second wave um so what I'd like
to do is show you more
clearly The Faculty numbers okay so this
is a little finer grain and you see
you've got a blip around 1970 I would
call that the the Sheila wood all blip
but anyway uh but then in
1996 then you have this really sharp
upward curve now Nancy said well that's
the version of curve it it was The deans
of the School of Science who were the
first that the faculty women went to
with their
complaints and and so it was the dean
really that who went then to Chuck vest
to say what do I do is it or not what do
I do but I'm informing you about these
complaints and I'm informing you that
I'm going to you know I'm going to have
to respond to them and Chuck vest said
um of course and okay but this is where
things start and then the second phase
is when Mark Kastner becomes dean of
science so so these are these are
individual stories it's not just
institutional
workings okay but the individuals of
course I'm just going to go through
these who really matter in the story
these are the 16
women who uh ended up in Bob bino's
office in
1994 uh now and this story is very it's
worth mentioning how that happened Nancy
Hopkins had a complaint about space
primarily but also committee assignments
and teaching assignments but space was a
big deal so so n this is Nancy bottom
bottom right there so this is
Communications form so the communication
she chose was to write a letter to the
dean but she asked somebody else to read
over the letter another woman in science
I forget which one it was but she asked
just read it over is this okay am I
being too shrill you know um and the
other faculty members said not only is
it a good letter I want to sign it too
and that started Nancy going around to
the other women in the School of Science
at that time and and then that led to a
meeting in the Dean's office where they
all sat around a table all 16 of them
plus the dean and and he has said that
he knew many of them were un happy he
knew things were going on but it was the
collective Narrative of 16 people
telling the same story in the sense of
these are the problems I have this is
how I react this is how I feel about it
then he said you couldn't dismiss it as
that individual being a crank or that
individ yeah it was the collective
weight of the storytelling so I just I
just I think this is really interesting
for how history works so I'm going to
leave these people up on the on the
screen so we can all admire them um
discussing about where things went from
here and I mean it went to a report and
another report and then a report that
got published in
1999 publicly uh which led to a lot of
publicity for MIT so so
um bino's account of all this which was
recently published in the MIT faculty
newsletter in the form of an obituary
for Chuck vest that he ends this
narration about this whole episode by
saying Academia has not been the same
since now he doesn't say we solv the
problem I I know he chose his words
carefully but Academia has not been the
same sense so my I I'd like to hear from
both of you just is this any history
that you ever heard or got or was there
any sense when you were coming on the
scene your PhD that you were on some
kind of a um in a moment where women in
science were on the verge of you know a
new life a better life um did did
anybody ever talk to you about this did
any of your mentors describe it
or I I mean I guess I can uh you know I
had one Mentor at Cornell Mary sansalone
who uh was really actually until I got
to
MIT one of the few
um
senior um colleagues I had that was a
woman um so it really wasn't until so
from undergrad you know until MIT I
worked pretty much only with with men um
both below and above me um and you know
because that was who was was around at
the various places I was um and then
arriving at MIT it was really
interesting because um you know it was
the first time that I was interacting
with these senior um female professors
and and that was that was really great
um but yeah so I you know I had I had a
mentor in college Mary selone and and
she I think um did talk about this
transformation um you know like partis I
really didn't have
any
negative gender related experiences kind
of going through school as an undergrad
as as a doctoral student um I mean
oftentimes I was the only woman in the
room but I didn't necessarily and I
think this has to do with how I was
brought up and my parents and family and
so forth I didn't necessarily notice it
or focus on it um I mean I think where
you start to notice it more is where the
sort of basis uh on which you're being
evaluated the way in which you're being
evaluated is less um you know less
quantitative less clear and a little bit
more subjective then you know then you
you start to be more conscious of it
um but it's yeah so I mean I I was
certainly aware of this transformation
that was taking place and it has been
great to see the changes and also the
changes in um you know the undergrad
graduate population and student
population engineering um you know in
the growth of of um of in the number of
female mentors that I that I that I now
have produ um yeah so first I guess I
would like to just take moment talk
about the report um and I I was very
well aware of that report when it came
out I had graduated at that point but I
had obviously um was kind of as a alumni
you know interested in what what was
happening and I I mean I just love that
report it's this interesting thing
actually that a lot of places think that
by admitting you have a problem you have
a problem right and uh it's actually the
opposite in my mind right that uh the
fact that MIT released this report is
what makes it probably the best place on
Earth to be a faculty and I think that's
really important to not CU somehow they
some people try to give them a lot of
flack for that of oh like MIT is a place
where they don't treat wom well like I
mean they dug into their own problem
they publicly released it and I tell you
I've been at other universities I am at
another University their problems aren't
any less because they don't talk about
them and um and in fact I think they're
more so I mean to me that that report
was amazing and it was and it was just
so nice I mean I think that's also one
of the reasons I I love being a
scientist it's just like you know know
there is a problem now let's get some
metrics on it right and let's really
actually understand that I think that's
the only way you transparency and and
metrics are the way we move forward so I
I I I love that report I love what Nancy
did I admire her admire her greatly
takes a lot of you know it's a bold move
it's it's to to particularly be the
first person to kind of talk about these
issues and not seem like you're just
somebody who's just complaining right to
say how do I articulate this in a way
that's productive and that moves the
field forward um as far as
who talked to me about it I mean I don't
I think it was honestly I think I was
reading it myself and personally
interested but it wasn't that we had
kind of discussions about it in that
context but you just sort of are always
talking about it in some way I mean like
I said my my greatest Mentor is Eric
Lander he's a man but um I man or woman
it's not that's not what I I focus on
it's what the strength of their
character and he himself has always been
an incredible supporter of women a lot
of his top management are women and he
is just an extraordinary sort of
understander of the importance of
diversity and um and a you know I've
been very lucky I think I think one of
the things you always realized and I
think Bill Clinton once said every every
person who's successful has one person
who believes in them and he was talking
about his mother in that context and I
think in your professional career as
well I do a lot of talks about
mentorship and about being a good mentee
and about finding a good Mentor and both
are important um but within that context
that every person who's successful has
somebody who is sort of looking out for
them as well um and uh anyway so that
within that context and we can kind of
go further I think Jessica made a lot of
really good comments about yeah I'd like
to get back I mean one just question is
whether you think choosing your Mentor
by gender is you know should that matter
is
that I mean I tend to agree with parties
that you know it really doesn't matter
I've had I've had wonderful male mentors
so at at in undergrad uh Steven SAS was
my main mentor and he really kind of set
me on the this path of research got me
into you know into the lab kind of my
first year there and and um yeah I mean
I think I think men as as well as women
um you know they they've sort of played
an equally important role as as a mentor
and and many you know sort of thoughtful
individuals whether they're men or women
understand these issues and kind of see
what's happening in this transformation
that's happening in the sciences and
engineering and bringing more females in
yeah go ahead I don't have to I don't
you can talk to each other yeah yeah
we're we're I mean I and I would say
that obviously I think there's a very
importance that there are women right
whether your spe your specific Mentor is
is a is a very different you know per in
personal experience and it's somebody
who you work well with and it it
shouldn't be defined by um gender or
ethnicity or any of that it's sort of
someone who speaks to you right so I
always say the way you choose your
Mentor is someone who you are inspired
by who you think is brilliant who you
trust who you will kind of be guided by
and who has the integrity
for uh that's sort of worthy of your
loyalty and and so I have often say I
made my career by trying to please my
mentor you know in science you there's
first author and last author papers so
it works well that way um and it's done
very well by me um and I think that
that's that's a relationship each person
should have obviously for some people
they really do gravitate and want it to
be a woman and I think there needs to be
an option for that and there needs to be
people that you can speak to um
obviously I have a very deep bond with
women and you know as men do with men I
think it's okay that that is the case um
peer-to-peer mentoring is also really
important so then Jessica and I have
gotten together at times and I think
that's really important I think it's
very important that you see up and you
see besides you and you see you know
lower down you see all of that you have
a community of individuals that you can
interact with I hadn't thought about the
sideways oh yeah yeah well yeah it's not
I mean you know like obviously in a
maybe in a in a club where you're trying
to meet people maybe the you know being
having a skewed uh situation might be
good but when you're looking at your
life you want to have that kind of
richness of experience um where you can
interact with other people you want to
say any more about about mentoring
either doing it or receiving it um well
I mean I think um I mean there you know
I've thought a fair amount about this um
and you mentoring students in my group
um and you know I should say that I
don't think we can put the genders into
different buckets because there's
personalities as well right so across
across um you know both groups there's
sort of a spectrum of personalities but
I do find that um with uh you know
oftentimes it is helpful to kind of work
with with uh female students in my group
and and Beyond to
really help build up
uh sort of their confidence and sort of
the way they're presenting their work I
do see that they you know maybe on
average is a little bit of a difference
in how uh women and men
present um present their ideas and the
confidence that they have in in doing so
you know you take the so I think that
there there is something there and um
you know some of the advice that I give
to my students is to just you know focus
on the content that was always what
helped me is to just focus on the
content and you know I was always really
interested in it curious and I think
when you do that it speaks to everybody
in the room
you know um and I'd like to hear from
pise um on this topic as well um you
know and then also I think a few other
pieces of advice you know not to be too
polite sometimes you know you know as
women we're sort of we're brought up to
be polite that's not a bad thing but you
don't want to be too polite you know if
you're interrupted in an exam you know
you want to make sure you get back to
your answer because you have to make
sure that you know the professor knows
that you know that answer for example
you know and um so you know mentoring
them mentoring them in that way I think
is important um and I think also you
know it goes both ways having a diverse
group I think is is um is useful sort of
from both sides you know diversity of
personalities genders you know
backgrounds Etc because you know they
all the students all pick up things from
each other as well and sort of best
practices and and um yeah so they I'd
love to follow up on this the word
confidence that came up and I I to me
that's one of those key words that it's
fuzzy but everybody there's something
there there when you're talking about
women in science or women period I um
Paris do you what uh I mean there's that
and there's also the the the idea that
the diversity of the group that's not
just gender based is being important I
don't know is that yeah sure I mean I
can speak all that I mean I'm I uh I
mean I
I I my mind's going a lot of different
directions and I could talk about my
group all day long so I love my group I
love and so I have like a story about
this and sort about that but I mean the
big thing is that for every member of my
group man or woman I I have a big line I
say that um I want you all to be
assertive it it's very important to me
that you're assertive lot of times are
like oh well you know I don't care about
that authorship I'm like you do just say
you do like it's okay to to and so the
idea is that I say I want every member
of my group to be assertive so that
they're never aggressive you see a lot
of there's an opposite thing that
happens where a lot of women just take
it they kind of get beaten down a lot
and they keep pretending like they don't
need things that they need and then
later they kind of randomly grab out at
something that they don't you know don't
deserve or don't because they don't know
they don't have an understanding of what
do I need to be successful how do I move
through my career so I really pushed my
students a lot to develop confidence to
develop what I call their inner voice um
to kind of understand what and and in
that way it makes you stronger in your
science like you need science science is
very difficult there's a lot of failure
no matter what else is going on in your
career and so you have to have an inner
strength and an inner voice and you need
environments that are going to uh
develop that and there are other things
with women that kind of make that
difficult they're not used to sort of
standing out you Cheryl stanberg makes a
very important point about that idea of
being bossy and how that that is a
negative connotation so women don't
understand how to assert their voice
without kind of going over the top and
seeming the kind of uh grading on people
and so I I try to work with them to
develop that to really to do that in a
smooth way so I think that's a very
important area another simple thing is
just the tamber of a woman's voice I
went to This Woman's Forum event um in
France where they brought in a a speech
therapist and you know it's funny
because they have all these like big
sessions with condalisa rice and all
sorts of world leaders and that was the
most popular session which is just get
together and learn how to speak and
women also need to learn how to get that
voice deeper just the simple Logistics
of being heard in a room is really
important and you have to actually do it
like um I have a lot of advice I give
for women but it's very important to do
all those things so you don't end up
becoming the woman that's bitter that is
the worst case scenario right um I I
tell women a lot of things that make it
about how difficult it is so I said I
kind of told you that I didn't have bad
experiences to a point doesn't mean I
haven't had a lot since um and that the
way I say it is I don't and and I tell a
lot of stories to women that are
frightening and I say I don't tell you
these stories so you go around thinking
that the world is unjust or that you'll
never make it I tell you so that you
realize that that there is a kind of not
a mind field but a a field you have to
get through of complications and I want
you to recognize they exist so you avoid
them right so you assert yourself to get
through them is that just really
important to understand what are true
obstacles and what are not obstacles so
that you don't go around kind of
assuming you'll always get beaten down
that is the worst case scenario you know
Nancy Hopkins always said that uh she
felt that discrimination against women
in science was very very age related
that up to a certain point up to a
certain point you're a young student
you're coming along this is fine we we
love you yeah yeah and then you know
then you begin to compete in the way or
or just get older I'm not sure whether
she just get in a space you're not used
to be yeah and become more and and so
you both refer to kind of like up to a
point so is the point related to age and
experience is is that you are you
talking about a timeline of life or or
or you think it's more a professional
Point can I take the first so I I went
through a really terrible experience
that I don't necessarily want to get
into but I I'll just kind of reflect on
it um what I say is you know um maybe
I'll I'll refer to something kind of a
popular uh so something Happ in in the
popular uh press or whatever which is
just I remember that election where both
Hillary Clinton um and why am I actually
Barack Obama no no no the woman
the what's that Sarah Sarah Palin there
you go wow I so any but yeah so both
both Hillary Clinton and Sarah palum
were both going up for election couldn't
ideologically be more different but what
I found was really interesting is the
same people hated them and and and had
the exact same high-pitch scream as to
how they described how they hated them
and um uh and then and then you also see
when women something like a Martha
Stewart situ when something goes wrong
and you get the same kind of reaction
and I said you know it took a long time
for people to get that high pitched
scream when they talked about George
Bush but boy can women just people men
and women go crazy uh at at women who
put themselves too far and so and and I
went through an experience where I was
sort of the down I became a third rate
citizen for a little while and I and I
saw the way everybody talked to me as
like impertinent Reckless careless I
mean the way that they talked to me was
just and it started to use a lot of kind
of gender biased words about not being
good and and the way I say is the way
you judge the moral grade of your
Society is not based on what happens
when a person's walking down the street
or in a coffee shop getting a coffee
it's what happens the minute that coffee
gets dropped right and what they say
like stupid and all this thing changes
right and so we stepped into a place
where suddenly we were being observed
when you're a student you're cute you're
a little bunny nobody really bothers
about you once you're in a space where
judgment is possible um and judgment
where people can have a snap reaction
and not censor themselves that's when
you see like the true situation and I
think it's either when you get too high
and then people start saying well that's
they're not worthy of that you know high
or low it's like if you try to go fly
too close to the Sun or kind of get
beaten then all of that comes out that's
when you start to see it so that would
be my sense is it's not necess it's not
it's not the age or anything like that
it's just what are you trying to do and
are you trying to step out of the bounds
of what is normal and what we can we all
have to kind of accept yeah I'm sure
we'll have some questions on this
yeah so so do you want to I'm sorry yeah
I mean I could I could add a little bit
to that I mean I think that you know up
to a point as a student you're um being
evaluated in very clear terms especially
if you're taking courses where you're
doing problem sets you're you know
turning in exams that are graded um it's
pretty straightforward you either got
that right or you got it wrong um and
you know so that that is
very you're you're evaluated in these
very objective terms and then you know
you get to a point where it's more about
you know subjectivity how good is that
work how are these people
perceiving well how you know the
perception you know and it's we don't
have clear metrics where you know you
start to to uh notice these gender
influences like until that point I
didn't really notice it but then it's
like oh okay you know the how I'm
speaking and the tone of my voice and
you you know what I'm wearing and all of
that you know may you know it never even
occurred to me that that was important I
mean it occurred to me but you know I
never really experience that personally
you know until this subjectivity comes
in and then you start to think oh okay
you know that you know I it's it's just
a realization that you are um being
perceived through the lens of gender to
some extent and um and then there's
another thing at play which is you know
you kind of go through your career and
you're like pretty said you know the
cute little bunny and then you know at
some point um you're you know you're no
longer pleasing yeah you know working to
please your professors and this and that
you know you're you're sort of you know
on kind of emerging to you know where
you're at the same level and you're you
know you may disagree on certain points
and you know so I think negotiating that
transition with without going too far
and becoming you know the most
loudmouthed person in the room and you
know also not being too timid I think
that sort of transition point is one
that um I certainly think it it it would
be useful to offer mentorship to female
to to women scientists and sort of
making that transition and that's so
being prepared for it not just mentally
but here are some things you can do to
to deal with the situation right because
I mean oftentimes these are unconscious
reactions that people are having and and
and they're not I you know there there
are situations where it's it's really
coming from a negative place but there
are other times where it's just you know
it's it's it's people are are
open-minded um and but you know it's
there are just certain things you can do
to to make sure that you know um you're
being evaluated um in you know along the
lines of of what you want to be and sort
of your message is really coming through
what do you wish you had
known um 15 years
ago
h i mean one example of something I wish
I had known or took me a few years in my
like time when I was at Oxford was um
uh well so something that happened where
was like an understanding that came to
me like Midway through was actually uh
that the people were still still sexist
then it did take me a little while to
figure that out so the I often say that
the one thing that was easier and and
there's a lot of things that were harder
so it's just just the one thing uh that
was easier about the time that we came
in compared to the time that you came
through is it was very clear what was
going on to you right I mean women
weren't even allowed in the schools to
begin with right so you understood that
people just didn't expect women to do
education to do well right so like a few
a generation before and so when you came
in you recognized that there was like a
very clear threat right that people did
not expect you to achieve did not expect
you to go somewhere but for us like
basically we hadn't experience
sexism uh through our early time and we
didn't think there was such a thing so
it took me about 3 years into my PhD
experience to understand why I always
felt that my ideas were not as good why
I always felt that like I was just not
good enough um it really took a long
time to articulate because everybody's
happy happy we get very very frustrated
at rhetoric where people walk around and
political correctness I think is a
dangerous thing because I don't want to
change Behavior I want to change
feelings and so everyone's walking
around being like oh no it's nothing and
then there's a roll of the eyes and
you're just like what just happened um
and like every time you had an idea it
just wasn't quite good enough but then
it same suddenly comes from somebody
else it's much better and I think that
that actually took me a really long time
and then one day I swe it was like a day
when I suddenly realized every woman in
this you know in this like uh Research
Center is depressed right and and every
woman in this Research Center thinks
that they are no good as a scientist I
was like I get it like it's just an
Insidious thing and it seeps into and if
people don't tell you I mean as soon as
I actually somebody said something to
the fact of like you're a woman you
can't do better it like was very
motivating I was like oh I get this okay
now I'll prove you wrong but when it
happens in a way that it's not
articulated you actually internalize it
and you think it's your problem so again
I and it's the same thing of why I tell
women there is sexism is so that that
never happens to them where they don't
recognize that that might be what's
going on but you don't want it to get to
the so point where you think everything
that doesn't happen for you is because
of that reason so the more we can get
like understanding of like what is the
this bias and then what is what we need
to you know sometimes your idea is just
bad and that also should be clear but
you should begin to understand which is
which and I think it I wish I had
recognized earlier on that this was just
a thing and then I had to have my own
internal clock I had to assert my inner
voice I had to assert myself and and
speak my inner voice it would have saved
me a couple years of my life I think
well but think of these women you know
it wasn't until a lot of them were quite
senior that they sat down in the room
together and discovered they all had the
same experience so at least
right you came to it a little earlier
than they they did
yeah so the question is what did you
what do you wish you had known 15 years
ago um yeah I mean I think this
understanding when I was going through
this transition
between um you know just feeling
supported by everybody the bunny to the
rabbit right right let's call it that
like T right you know sort of feeling
supported by everyone and then suddenly
it's like oh you know that person isn't
you know responding to what I'm saying
and that you know person is shooting
that down and you know and sometimes as
partis mentioned it's just you know you
say something it's not a good idea but
but you know sometimes you say something
and it is a good idea and I wish I had
um gotten to that realization sooner
because you know you do waste a little
bit of time kind of internalizing this
saying oh you know what's going on and
and kind of learning also Alo how to
make that transition because I think
there are ways um and um you know that's
something that I do try to I mean I I
don't have sort of a ready-made list
right now but I sort of try you know
over time to reflect on that so I can
share those insights with my students um
you know and and kind of making that
transition and I think also having more
senior women just present as Parise
mentioned a while back you know just
around I think that's really important
because I mean that's that's I think
that's a really it's a huge
deal um I I just have a one more
question before we open it up and that's
about Oxford I mean did you feel like
it's the same there as here or was it a
very different miler in the you know for
women in science just positive or
negative I'm just curious how much
travels across the Atlantic in terms of
culture yeah um well Oxford an
interesting place right because you I
mean if you're one of in one of the
older colleges you go to to have dinner
and there's high table and it's you know
literally a table up on a stage with um
you know everyone's dressed in their
subf fusk and uh you know up on the
stage it's primar it's really only men
there may be like one woman and then
every now and then you get invited as a
grad student to sit at high table you're
the only woman you know in this sort of
group of and there are so many
Traditions you know around like retiring
to the den after you know after dinner
and uh passing around glasses of port
and you know um various other you
know drinks rituals and so forth so it's
it is very those rituals are very malale
dominated um and uh so in that sense
it's it's different um I mean it's
different in a lot of ways I had a I had
a great um me you know a couple of
mentors Christopher viney and David
Caine and you know and they were I don't
know in my research I guess I I I it
wasn't until a little bit later that I
went through this s transition to the
rabbit as we talked about but um you
know I think I think um yeah I mean it's
just a it's a very different environment
I I I don't know that it it you know
these gender issues we're talking about
would be better or worse there it's it's
in general I guess you have a little
less exposure to you know faculty and I
found I don't know if you found that I
mean certainly you have more exposure to
people outside of your field through
your college and graduate students from
other fields and so forth but in terms
of um you know the faculty at large I
think you have a bit less exposure so in
that sense it could be even more you
know it could be quite isolating so if
you did run into a problem I would be
really worried about you know sort of
getting out of that yeah I would
actually say just I would speak I think
that it's hard to be a woman in any
country in the world but I do still
think that United States of America is
the best place to be a woman that a lot
of other places are way further behind
and the gender roles are way less
defined and um and having spent time
internationally I recognize that
actually in America it's not like they
don't have the problems but you can say
something and somebody will be like
we'll pay attention so that that's
basically thing I mean there's you know
we still have um Corruption of our
Senators you know that's a problem but
if you're caught taking money there's a
repercussion whereas in some places in
Africa there's no repercussion and in
that kind of context and the same thing
of you know there is plenty of sexism in
the United States as well but if it
happens and someone catches it it's kind
of you know it can be if they if you can
get attention for it you can people know
it's it's supposed to be wrong I don't
actually think that even in Europe those
gender roles are that defined and I know
a lot of women um that are very unhappy
uh I think uh particularly you said
women they're trying to be professional
I actually feel I like I actually had a
wonderful time in Oxford and I have a
wonderful Mentor there and and all of
that but I I do think all of the female
graduate students were depressed and
felt bad about themselves and that's not
great all the ones I knew we even had
like you know we had all the roads
there's a roads women like knitting club
that just sat around and talked about
why they were depressed all the time so
um there there was there was issues
there were issues and and I think that
they will also come forward and getting
better and better but um but
it's it's hard anywhere in the world to
try to try to become a professional
woman to be taken seriously in in a
culture that just for so many years it's
like you you said it's so embedded um
we're we're as a human Community we're
trying a very different experiment to
have half of the population get into the
workforce that wasn't there before and a
lot of people are slow to it but um I
think America's moved the most quickly
and responds the most to these kinds of
things all right that that is an
encouraging note to to turn
to everybody else who's
here must have questions comments yeah
just but do if you would stand in front
of the mic just so we get a recording
thank you and would you introduce
yourself sure my name is Esther schrat
can you hear me okay and I hate to be a
note of discordance but I will be one
anyway CU I'm in computer science and
there's no women in that either there
remain no women in that and I know at
least two professors in this University
who I would say were very sexist to me
and impacted my career horribly so then
when I went to the student person who's
supposed to help you she just said well
you know that money's gone they spent it
you know the money they owed me I mean
that's an answer so no nobody cared
nobody cared and I did complain and I
think those guys are back in the 70s
what I would really like to see happen
is that what goes on in Industry needs
to go on in University in Industry they
would haul
everybody in and all these places like I
know so and so made a big Gaff with his
um comment about women it was a Google
or I forget already the company it was
but Microsoft you know he made a big
gapff but they still Microsoft and all
those other people Oracle Google they
haul everybody in and give them a talk
about diversity that does doesn't happen
here so the gods who have their tenure
and their chairs they can go on be
whatever they want and just say oh my
God she's just no
good we really in computer science have
a long way to
go I I absolutely agree so I like I said
my own situation I like I said I won't
go into details but I know exactly what
you mean and you feel like helpless and
no one's going to listen to you and this
is the way it's going to happen I in
this situation I had a mentor a single
mentor who looked out for me and that's
the only reason I left standing which is
why I do think they're so important but
I no I agree I'm not I'm saying that I
probably it's a more of a general in
other places in the world it's like at
least we can sit in the room and be
horrified by your story like in some of
these other countries nobody would be
horrified by that at all they'd be like
oh and what what happened right so um I
I do recognize and I do think Academia
in a lot of ways is the most backwards
absolutely and it is because in in
general it wasn't designed and there was
like a there's no intelligent design I
would say about how the academic
structure was brought up and it is
extraordinarily hierarchical um and I do
think the things like the that gender
report were really important because
they actually shed light on well this is
the issue um and I think that for uh
like you said the transparency that you
can get are going to be critically
important um yeah there's a lot more I
could talk about very specifically about
your issue but I have heard that I've
become after my own like terrible
experiences I've become a kind
unofficial omut person for a lot of
people who know that they need to talk
to me about something going wrong I'll
get incensed for you and I'll try to
figure out how to help you and sometimes
I can and sometimes we can only laugh
about it you know and try to figure out
how to get you out of a situation where
you ever have to interact with those
people again because the often I also
say this I said there's no there's truly
there are truly terrible people out
there in the world many of them and I
often tell you that they exist so that
you can just avoid them um and maybe I'm
not saying that we should all just keep
avoiding this person they should be
taken to task but for your own personal
good the best thing to do is kind of get
out of that situation get into a place
where you can be uh appreciated you know
the this it's making me think that the
title of the session is is not quite
precise because as women in science
we're talking about women in academic
science and and I I know I've had a lot
of conversations with a lot of people
who have gone into business you know in
either you know racial minorities or
women and they're much happier um so
there's a whole world out there beyond
the university which is not Nirvana we
know that too but still it is things are
done differently and and it is an
alternative uh more questions yes hi I'm
Eric State and I'm a graduate student in
comparative media studies um and you've
both talked a little bit about issues
that you've experienced that seem to be
in the lab and in research groups um one
of the main complaints that I've heard
from female faculty in the humanities
not specifically here but in general is
about things like course load and
teaching load and you know having male
faculty um who actually get more you
know time off to go write their books
and you know continue their careers
where you know they find as women they
end up teaching you know more classes
than seems like they ought to be um and
I'm wondering if that's also something
that that's happening in The Sciences if
that's something that you've experienced
I know the like the credentialing
mechanisms are different so books versus
articles I don't know if that actually
has an effect on the time that you get
to sort of do your own work and how
those effects play out in your
experience but I was just curious if you
had you know something to share about
that yeah I mean I think so before I
took this faculty position I actually
had a number of um senior colleagues at
the Santa Fe Institute that just told me
like time and again like just saying no
to stuff don't say you know I think to
the point so when I came here I actually
did say no to a lot of things and
probably you know upset some people but
um but yeah so I I you know and I think
MIT is pretty good about looking out for
junior faculty in that in that way um
but I think what you're talking about I
mean I can totally I I totally think
that that's happening on many campus and
probably here as well you know um there
is this um you know there was an article
in the New York Times um a while back
this is a slightly different issue but
it was something like Madame CEO get can
you get me a coffee something along
those lines you know there is a little
bit of that you know so it's like it's a
little different from what you're
talking about but I think it's related
where you know I think as a woman
sometimes you get asked to do things and
it's not just getting a cup of coffee
cuz now we we kind of know okay that's
off limits we can't do that but it's
like you know what are you asked to do
like versus you know a male colleague
where that maybe they'd go to your
assistant first before going to you to
ask for that particular thing so I think
there are these things are real and and
and they do happen I think to the extent
um we can collect data on um on you know
teaching load and so forth I guess there
was a Yale report in 2012 that focused
on um salary uh among uh women faculty
as compared to male faculty you found
this like you know the significant if um
significantly lower salaries for female
faculty but I think you know as
universities we should be able to we
should keep track of what people are
doing and review that and just make that
part of you know the endof year review
process for the Department look at you
know who's doing what and and you know
who's carry is anybody carrying too much
of the load you know Eric after the
the uh report that Paris was describing
about women in science at MIT um the
provos ordered all the other schools all
the other four schools to do a similar
report to study just this kind of thing
I mean space was less an issue in a
non-lab environment but teaching low
time off salaries and so forth so each
school did you know did a data analysis
and where there were problems again and
the idea was if you have the numbers
then you can correct them you know
though in it's interesting we've had
this
conversation for you know an hour and we
haven't mentioned uh motherhood uh and
family time and and that actually is
where women often feel like I've had a
baby I have small children you know
where's how how does that fit in
especially in a day and age where
fathers are doing a lot of uh work too
um with children so uh you know again
one of the results of the women in
science study was to look at family
leave policy and and essentially to
change at MIT so that if a woman Bears a
child during the pre- tenure period the
tenure clock is extended by a year just
and don't ask for it you get it and it
was very important not to be an option
but to be a
requirement um you know for obvious
reasons so so that is another area where
you know the you know when you have a
family when you have babies then all
these questions come up yet again about
what's fair
what's egalitarian yeah and I think one
of the nice things about mit's policy is
that um fathers also get you know get
that that leave but I guess there you
know and I don't know if this is true
the stories that you hear that you know
there were cases where uh fathers were
taking the leave but they weren't the
primary caregivers and so they were
using that time to get tons of work done
meanwhile someone else was taking care
of the kid um so I think mit's changed
that now so you have to show that you're
the primary caregiver yeah no free free
writers here that yeah but uh but but I
mean this is I mean it's just we're
laughing because all these things you
know they're
bureaucratic you want to regularize them
you really depend on the institution to
have rules but people are people you
know everybody's different kids are kids
and uh and it's not it's actually not a
laughing matter but it's sort of you can
laugh or cry you know so as well
laugh um did you have another thank you
yeah thank you thank you any more
questions ah
please yeah um I was actually just gonna
you want to introduce myself I'm Anna
noag gradski I'm a master's candidate in
the MIT science writing program and I
worked in labs for eight years before
coming here um in plant biology mostly
so I was actually just going to mention
that it's interesting that you um said
that the US is one of the best places
for women today when the US is one of
the only only a tiny handful of
countries in the world that doesn't have
any mandatory paid maternity leave um
and no parent no mandatory paid parental
leave at all um and it's interesting I
mean I like to think about large
structural things that we can do that
will help women and I think that paid
parental leave is the the biggest one I
can think of I'm first of all very
interested in you if you have ideas of
other large structural changes we can
make rather than just relying on
individual women to you know stand up
for themselves which of course is also
necessary but um and second I'm
wondering if you have any ideas because
I'm ever hopeful of how we can actually
get mandatory paid parental leave in the
US um so that that is that's a big one
and you're you're right about that I
mean and I don't I could be wrong right
I mean it might be that Germany's
actually the best place to be a woman
and I and I missed it so yeah okay so
that that that's probably um uh the
there's a lot of cultures that are not
great that I have seen um but I would
say so I came back very happy to be in
the United States and to be to make a
career here and again and like you said
there are many structural major problems
but at least you can Spar about it
there's one funny thing in England the
just American women might be the most oh
yeah they might be the most hated right
there something about us we just I mean
literally every single person at Oxford
kind of hated me there in the academic
system and I think it's cuz we they all
probably look at as and say impertinent
it's just kind of cross the board so you
can't really show you can't have like
Gump shin and show like it's just not
proper or something like that so so it
may also be a being an American woman in
the in that kind of European context I
maybe I'm just not also not handling it
the right way right so I just like that
we can yell about it and say this CS
Professor is terrible like we can we can
say those things and we actually have
enough energy to say them where whether
we get anywhere is often not the case
but we can at least talk about it but
you speak to action and I think that is
actually a very important thing so I
don't so I don't have a child that's
it's part of part of the issue of wom in
science neither do I I hope to uh one
day whether mine or adopted or or or had
a pet rat that I swear was my child so
um uh I love things and I i' like to
nurture something um but uh so I haven't
thought about that specifically and I do
think that that obviously is a major
issue um so and I'll I'll let others
speak to that if they're going to um but
as far as other ideas that I have for um
structural changes I think the biggest
thing is that idea of metrics and
accountability and transparency and the
places where you see like this idea this
academic environment in which like a
crazy things happen I think we need a
real good structure and it and it
shouldn't be I think I think I'll just
talk about the academic stance the
academic the problem with Academia is
the whole structure is not designed in a
way that is was in all like
intelligently designed the fact of the
matter is you have these students they
do undergraduate in science they do
graduate school in science to do postto
in science and suddenly they're a
manager which doesn't make any sense
many of them may be like mildly on the
asper Spectrum many of them just may not
be nice people but they're just good at
what they do and suddenly they are
caring for the lives of people
underneath them right so that's already
a problem and and to their credit
they've also gotten no training no
incentives and no kind of thing in order
to become better people so that's kind
of a broken system to begin with and
then if they get really good at what
they do somehow they become the chair
and then they kind of can and move this
through we haven't it's the same thing I
mean we've got bigger problems why is it
that our president is someone we should
have a beer with and why isn't it not
somebody who runs a really good
organization I mean we make silly
choices about who to put in charge of
certain things and I think that overall
the if the entire system was overhauled
where we did actually say that you know
these people that that people get
training that people get it that you
create a culture in which there's this
transparency and opy and and mentorship
to do the job you are doing we we'd be
better off um you you know and and then
as that system kind of progresses so in
my mind the there's a much bigger
problem which is the culture of academic
science is a little bit broken I mean
graduate lots of graduate students are
depressed and lots of them are under
mentors who abuse them or take away
credit on their papers or you know I
mean or don't or just are neglectful um
so I think that that's a bigger thing I
think sometimes if you solve the
systemic problems for all people you'll
help women a lot too and women have an
own specific set of issues because
there's also this sexism that goes with
it but that problem that you describe
happens to plenty of men as well it's
somebody who for whatever reason doesn't
like the cut of your jib and is going to
make you feel bad about yourself or just
doesn't you know have their head in the
right place so I think that that is a
bigger thing I mean another specific
thing sorry I can keep going things like
ad boards or misconduct investigations
that's another place where there's a
black hole that people go into is like
and I've seen this with a lot of
students where again and and I and
you're reading a lot about the sort of
sexual harassment on on college campuses
problem where it goes all wrong why are
your professors running a legal case
when they have no capacity why do we put
people on committees that they have no
competency for I mean and one place
where women get overloaded is on
committees because you always need a
woman on a committee but like also on
those committees those committees are
just poorly structured and uh if you one
more thing if you look at the CV of a
professor their CVS do not make sense
they're on like 14 companies they run a
research lab they teach five classes
they're on 25 committees I mean we're
all exhausted because our CVS don't make
sense and don't fit into the day of one
person let alone six people well those
people are on committees that run these
kinds of things like thinking about
quality of life they have no quality of
life themselves what are they doing
thinking about quality of life we need
to empower administrators who are
extraordinary who are all altruistic
enablers who make sure good things
happen instead of putting one more
famous person on a committee to think
about the quality of life right um so
that's a structural problem that we need
to think about yeah and I'll just add
one thing to that um I mean forums like
this you know having talks as as was
mentioned by one of the earlier um uh
participants who asked a question um you
know talking about some of these issues
whether it's you know the get me a
coffee syndrome or um you know kind of
transitioning from student to peer how
to navigate that um you know what what
your supervisor should be at like what's
reasonable for your supervisor to ask
you to do I mean to parisa's point as
when I was a grad student I remember
thinking I mean I I really enjoyed my um
PhD advisors but just kind of looking
around I remember thinking you know when
you're a grad student your advisor is
one of the most important people in your
in your life U maybe the most important
person and I never want to forget that
when I'm an adviser because you have the
power to make somebody's life miserable
or you know much more enjoyable and
you're also really um influencing what
you know they can then do Beyond grad
school so I think really and that's
that's not just an issue for women got
me right here I'm thinking about my grad
students I'm like am I taking care of
them that's actually it's true it's true
that's big responsibility you know it's
not just you know as as pretty mention I
think that's more of a you know for for
everybody the whole system I think those
are conversations we need to be having
and I think some sometimes just having a
conversation about these issues you know
articles in in the press and
conversations like this it just you know
then when you see it happen you think oh
yeah you know maybe I shouldn't be
asking that person to get me a coffee or
you know whatever it is your you know
and and and so I think that's a really
important um sort of action that
universities can
take okay any more any more
questions have one or sort of these are
these are really uh two uh two issues I
have that I simply they're not really
questions but I'd like your reaction to
them comments um one is there's been a
lot of both you know public media
coverage and and some research studies
on the problem of unconscious bias you
know the study at Yale where they sent
out resum identical resumés with male
and female and urm typical uh names and
got the results that we all know know
about the um the article in New York
Times by a wonderful creative writing
professor at Michigan who started in
life as I think the first undergraduate
to get a ba in physics undergraduate
woman to get a ba in physics at Yale and
the the bias that persists in the Y
physics
department unnoticed even by the then
female head of that department these
kinds of things so um problem of course
with unconscious bias is it's
unconscious which makes it you know
difficult to fix um and I'm wondering if
you have particular strategies Andor
thoughts for rendering the unconscious
conscious and therefore addressable by
by explicit reaction explicit action
and in my mind and maybe only there the
sort of next thing that I've been
thinking about is connected to that
which is there's an enormous amount of
writing now and incredibly depressed
graduate student and postdoc blogs um
about the academic bottleneck the fact
that we are drastically overproducing
quote unquote
um graduate students in the Sciences as
as you know people in the humanities are
used to this you know horrible
overproduction of of phds for whom there
are no jobs and it's now being
explicitly discussed in The Sciences
even though it's been a problem for a
lot longer there um and that creates uh
stresses that that often play out in uh
in gender and race in in gender and race
identifiable ways uh and I wonder if
again if you've sort of as as heads of
labs Etc have addressed that in your own
thinking uh yeah well I could start um
so um yeah I mean I think this
unconscious bias um uh question is an
important one and I think one of the
ways it manifests itself is actually in
women's self perception the perception
of themselves um and their level of
confidence right and that was I mean
that's something that a number of people
writing on the topic have highlighted
and and I think it it rings true
um you know because as you know as was
mentioned I think if you're sort of
getting a reaction from the outside
world and it's it's not really explicit
it's not talked about then you might
internalize it and that can lead to you
know less confidence and how you're
presenting your ideas and so forth so I
think that's something that the more
it's it's talked about I think the
better and and we can recognize it in
ourselves and our students support you
know our students and it's it's
something that you can you can work
through I think again you know what I
tell my students is really focus on the
content focus on what you're most
interested in what do you want don't
don't worry about what people are
thinking of you what do you want them to
know like what what are you most
interested in and kind of that's as a
you know way to deal with some of these
questions around you know the people
have talked about the impostor syndrome
and you know am I really worthy of this
position should I do I deserve to be
here um so I think that's important and
then I think the other thing that um I I
guess touches on on um what you
mentioned is this idea that and this
actually I think came up in the New York
Times article you were were were
referring to where uh this yell
Professor was talking about um you know
kind of going through school and and not
doing so well and exam physics exams and
so forth and you know eventually
succeeding um um as a professor and I
think you know that's something I can I
can relate to is this idea you know she
attributed that to kind of trying to
think about the problems that she was
being given in the way that her her male
colleagues were thinking about them when
she kind of let go of that and and
decided to start solving the problems
using her own method and her own
thinking then suddenly it all made sense
and she really progressed and that's
something I can relate to personally I
think there were times you know kind of
growing up where I thought oh I'm not
you know thinking about things in the
right way you know I had this one math
class I came home and my you know I told
my mom I can't do it and she was like
what what are you talking about you can
do it you know and so we went in we met
with the professor and then it became or
with the teacher you know and it became
clear afterwards that the problem was
that I was you know I wasn't I wasn't
thinking about things in my way I was
thinking about things the way the
teacher was you know describing them and
that it you know that didn't make sense
to me so I thought well I have to think
about things like that but you know it
it wasn't the case so when I sort of
started to think about things in my own
way then it all made sense and and I was
able to progress so I think that's um
you know something that again if we can
highlight that then
more uh you know women and you know
students in general I think will will
sort of feel more comfortable taking
their own paths and sort of building up
their own confidence um and I think by
the way and that's a kind of getting off
topic but this this idea of really um um
you know this idea of people thinking in
different ways is one of the reasons why
you see increase performance in diverse
research groups that's something I've
observed firsthand in my own
group okay and then we I'll I'll second
question I'll go the first and the
second then you can do the second after
so um for the first question about
unconscious bias I mean I adore mazarine
vanish I just think she's the coolest um
she's actually my was my mentor for a
little while and and and it's what's
what's awesome about her is not only is
she just uh brilliant and uh and
insightful but you she's very open I
mean and she had said often that she
when she took the test herself she she
kind of was failed and was like sort of
shocked by that and I think that that
the truth of the matter is that a lot of
people I mean everyone has unconscious
bias women are obviously very subject to
that and often you see that women are
womenon women kind of uh sexism is
really problematic um and we and we see
that that all the time too but um but
even in that in the case of mazarine I
know that it's just well-meaning people
who ever have ever kind of caught off
guard to realize that they were
participating this would be horrified um
but don't realize these things have kind
of gotten into their unconscious and um
and I think that that speaks to the
point that Jessica made earlier about
the more we make this transparent the
more we move the needle forward because
more people can catch themselves like do
you realize like what you're doing or do
you realize how that sounds or just
checking people and it also just makes a
difference about um
the thing is it's it's like basically
there's a lag that happens we are moving
forward we have moved forward it isn't
that we haven't it just takes a while
and and unconscious is the thing that
takes the longest to kind of clear up
right but if we behave well our children
will see something different and then
maybe they will then just be different
where we're not quite all all there yet
so I'm hoping that it's a couple
Generations will move forward a little
bit um but I remember when I when I
started having like the most trouble
where I was really I it was like I said
late in my career probably my 30s where
I was like the world is not just and
things are bad and I started to
recognize all these things and and
there's a part of me that became a
little bit of like a radical and I
wanted to go out and just do this I
wanted to write a book about you know
all the problems that happened and
something I really wanted to do and in
the end I realized that actually if I do
that then then I haven't really made a
difference because I'm yet another woman
who dropped out of a scientific track to
go do something that wasn't scientific
and so ultimately you know I I ended up
staying with it and and I decided to be
just the change yourself right and that
fundamentally if we just stick with it
and we show then the community changes
and the culture changes and there's more
women at the high levels and naturally
even if we don't become Advocates it
just is different because we think
differently I mean my lab I take them
all to Florida every year and we do a
ridiculous Retreat we have holiday cards
we create a different environment that
you know it's a clown show in some ways
but it's a environment that probably you
know uh would not have happened you know
in the' 70s I don't you know think that
my professors at Oxford we saying like
everybody we going to you know Typhoon
Lagoon um but I you know I I just think
differently and if more women go to the
top than everybody you know than the
cultures around you think differently um
to to the second question you have about
the graduate student situation I think
the graduate students have a lot of
there it's a hard thing being a graduate
student worrying about your long-term
trajectory in my mind is the least of it
right the worst of it is just is this
environment nurturing and cult and um
nurturing for you to really do something
exceptional in science and to innovate
something new um and to not get lost on
the path going through this ambiguity
right there is I I mean I'm very kind of
watching for my graduate students to
achieve this thing which is an
extraordinary complicated thing which is
taking something that's very all over
the place and then creating a unit of
information into the world that training
to me when you do that thing when you
actually take all of this noise and turn
it into a beautiful signal or all this
chaos and create something that's a book
isn't an exceptional piece of training I
wish everybody had I wish my president
had I wish my you know Senators had I
wish people in Industry had I think that
a PhD is an amazing degree to have I I
had an MD I had a PhD and I'd say yeah
the MD feels like more work and
obviously that track and the grades you
have to get are really hard but it's
very prescriptive you just come to
school and you do the assignment and you
get through whereas a PhD is you are you
you have to take an ownership to it so I
think it's an exceptional training and I
think we should just think differently
about that problem it's not like oh but
why are we getting all these phds if
there's no professorships professorship
is not that great of a gig I've done it
and frankly you may see me in Industry
soon and I think that we should just
encourage more of our phds to take that
training and build companies and go into
uh policy and transform things I wish
more you know more people had phds and
that we took that and use that to change
the world okay and and I will just say
for the undergraduates here there's also
a senior thesis or any piece of work
where you get it together uh that's
that's that's great yeah and I mean I
was actually that was exactly my answer
to your second question um I mean just
just to add a slight bit to it um yeah I
mean I think you know given the problems
that governments face industry
faces having that the ability to um
think analytically to um create signal
from noise kind of to research something
you know look into a problem in depth
and come up with your own conclusions I
think is useful beyond the university
and I don't know how to get that message
out there maybe it's something between
you know maybe it's it's both
recognizing ourselves what what the PHD
is giving students you know and sort of
what general skills um that sort of
gives them to be leaders in industry in
government and Academia sort of making
that more explicit um or maybe it's it's
you know kind of um more Outreach um you
know working more closely with
government and Industry at earlier
stages introducing our students to you
know I think there are lots of ways we
could move that situation
forward I I think I I will try to wrap
this up by just saying that both of you
are in areas of science where you really
are trying to address big problems of
the world the biggest and and it really
helps to relate women and science to
that goal and and if nothing else I
think talking about women in science
reminds us what the big goals should be
why why we're all in this business to
start with and the the system is broken
in many ways as the parent of a postto
for men or women it's it's there's a lot
that needs to be better because those
big problems are there and we need a
system that really encourages people to
address them and not get so depressed
along the way or or drop out so it's so
often the case if you think about making
the system better for everybody than
women it benefit too but uh not
only thank you for coming I really I
really appreciate your time and and
especially our panelist time let's thank
you